welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and the Flash is widely considered
to be a financial flop making only 55
million dollars domestically in its
opening weekend 66 million including
Monday and well below the 85 million the
studio is projecting it to make it's a
shame because I think many elements in
this movie really work and it does not
deserve to flop like this in fact I
think it should have been DC's Avengers
end game or Spider-Man no way home penny
at Warner Brothers probably thought it
was gonna be at some point so I'm gonna
break down what happened here did this
movie ever have a chance and what
timeline of decisions led to this
underwhelming arrival hey subscribe to
all three channels in the new rockstars
Network this channel for Easter egg
breakdowns and your burning questions
the break room for our instant reactions
and our after shows including inside
Marvel the secret evasion after show and
the Deep dive for special film analyzes
from me okay variety reported that the
Flash's underperformance spells even
bigger trouble for Warner Brothers as a
whole that production budgets plus
marketing for Shazam Fury of the guides
The Flash Blue Beetle and aquabanda in
the lost kingdom will total between mean
1.1 billion and 1.2 billion dollars they
quote an industry veteran who said The
Flash should be opening at 120 million
dollars domestic and they called it an
unmitigated disaster that Variety
article includes a Nifty infographic
comparing the profits of every DC movie
since Man of Steel now while it is still
early you can see how important the
domestic opening box office is in the
overall total and for the flash to make
less than Black Adam in October is not a
good sign the flash of course struggled
with a problematic lead actor in Ezra
Miller with Messy legal troubles from
the past few years the Studio's response
was to market the film more as a Batman
movie heavily featuring Michael Keaton's
Batman in the high profile trailer shown
during the Super Bowl in February and
other costly TV spots aired during the
NBA finals in January incoming head of
DC films James Gunn called The Flash
quote one of the best superhero movies
I've ever seen and Discovery CEO David
zotslav called it quote the best
superhero movie Warner began screening
versions of this movie the week of
cinemacon in April what was shown in
these early press screenings was not the
finished cut reportedly including no
post-credits scene and cutting to
credits before we saw the face of the
final Batman Cameo who steps out of the
car now this Variety article in the
discourse on social media have begun to
point their fingers at various possible
reasons superhero fatigue Multiverse
fatigue and bad VFX are often thrown
around but Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
and Spider-Man across the spider-verse
both were incredibly successful films
the latter of which Dives deeper into
the Multiverse than any other superhero
movie has Black Panther's third Act was
some of the most unfinished VFX I've
ever seen in a movie but people still
love that movie so bad VFX isn't reason
alone that a movie underperforms and I
also disagree that this movie's writing
or direction are to blame like sure you
can take issue with Andy machietti's
camera work and his pacing or Christina
Hudson's dialogue and story structure
but compared to Black Adam compared to
Aquaman I don't know I think if you
recast the lead and swap out some cameos
in this movie this is a great
coming-of-age story about Destiny and
sacrifice with some great actions and
pretty funny gags but before we start
yelling at me look movies frequently
have mismatched audience scores versus
critics averages movie quality is just a
matter of opinion ultimately and there
are just more structural issues with the
flash that we can point to so let's list
five
and Swire The Flash underperformed one
the Ezra of it all to the Betrayal of
the Zack Snyder fandom three the James
Gunn DC reset for the publicity campaign
and five fan service misalignment so
starting with the first of those Ezra
Ezra Ezra Ezra now look audiences have
supported some actors going through
legal issues before like when Robert
Downey Jr was cast as Iron Man he had
some complicated run-ins with the law
but really the issue with Ezra Miller is
that Warner chose to sideline the actor
from doing any publicity for this film
and that plus all the late night shows
being off the air due to the writer
strike Warner did not have a lead to go
out there and sell the film and before
you say that that's not that important
look at Black Adam by comparison that
movie totally benefited from Dwayne The
Rock Johnson frequently promising that
the hierarchy of power in the DC
Universe is about to change this guy
personally lobbied to get Henry Cavill
in the movie and told everyone that
there was going to be a Superman
Showdown before the movie even came out
but that ties in with reason number two
the Betrayal of the Zack Snyder fandom
the release of Snyder cut now restore
the Snyder verse movement is real folks
and it's not all just bullies on Twitter
but really A lot of the Snyder fans are
just regular folks who want to see DC
films that don't in their eyes
aggressively erase or retcon the
continuity of the Snyder era like you
don't see an angry reaction to movies
like Matt Reeves the Batman because it's
clearly in a separate universe but
movies like The Flash aren't supposed to
be in the DC EU We Begin the movie
partnering Barry with Ben Affleck and
then we learned that they did shoot
scenes with Henry Cavill but they
removed them from the movie and by doing
things like that you just guarantee that
the most organized online fan movement
right now are gonna boycott your movie
opening weekend with the angriest of
them doing everything they can to
toxicify the word of mouth online and
that's just an unforced error that you
do not need now you've heard me talk
about raid Shadow Legends before but
today we have a true expert here to tell
us all about the newest features in raid
Professor death knight take it away
professor professor death knight here
from Talaria University who legally not
a school with a math problem if you
create a hit mobile game in 2019 how
many champions will you have now over
700 okay so who's the best champion in
Talaria now well Ultimate Death Knight
of course the greatest smartest kindest
sorry I know it's so annoying when
teachers talk about their kids oh okay
Professor sure but what about the other
factions not only does raid have
hundreds of rad Champions it also has 15
amazing factions faction Pop Quiz can
you name the latest faction if you said
The elusive Sylvan Watchers you're right
okay class any questions wow that looks
awesome do you ever get nervous about
being replaced the nervous who said
anything about being nervous it
certainly wasn't me oh it was you yes
I'm nervous what if they introduce some
guy named Mega Death Knight that's it
for today class your homework is the
download raid just kidding I know you've
already done that so no homework call of
the Arbiter is in full swing Now to
celebrate this epic limited series raids
adding some of the new characters from
the series Champions that you can play
with in game the first one is our attack
a mighty orc warlord artax gonna be
available to everyone for free just log
into raid for seven days between now and
July 24th and he is yours if you haven't
started playing raid yet use my link in
the description to get or scan my QR
code to get insane bonuses like an epic
Champion Talia and other useful things
all the treasures that you get in game
will be located right up here and come
join me in this world of Brave China
Legends reason number three James Gunn's
DC reset so in January James Gunn
announced his new plan for the DC
Universe and you know I'm pretty
optimistic about the Gods and Monsters
slate however to announce that plan in
January before the four scheduled DC
movies that were released in 2023 just
signaled to a lot of viewers that these
four movies did not matter to the Future
franchise continuity and again while
some superhero movies can stand alone
like Matt Reeves the Batman or Joker
these 2023 films were initially pitched
and conceived to be part of the DC EU
continuity they depend on that inter
your connectivity and had Warner just
held off on guns announcement until
January 2024. who knows fans might have
been a bit more invested in each of
these 2023 titles but in January they
kind of set them up to seem irrelevant
Issue 4 the publicity campaign so yeah
the studio screened unfinished versions
of this movie that excluded the final
twist to press into early audiences
perhaps to avoid spoilers from leaking
but you should not make a movie that
depends on that with its final shot this
resulted in some early reactions
spreading the word about one version of
a movie and then normal audiences seen
it release week seeing something
completely different ending with an
entirely different taste in your mouth
and one less tooth all these over
positive tweets and statements just
raise expectations to a place where some
more cynical viewers start rolling their
eyes the Variety article quoted another
executive who said when they called it
the greatest superhero movie if it's not
correct you're setting yourself up to
fail in this environment it's better to
under promise and over deliver bringing
this to the last and what I think is the
most important issue here fan service
misalignment yes this movie did its own
thing with the flashpoint storyline like
there's no Thomas Wayne Batman there's
no reverse flash there's no Atlantean
Amazonian War but you know superhero
movies always do that and I think
opening weekend audiences are just used
to it like Captain America Civil War the
movie did not really follow the Civil
War comic event but the issue here is if
you've been a fan of The Flash in the
past decade chances are you've been
watching at least some of the CW series
starring Grant Gustin Esther Miller's
Barry Allen even crossed over to this
series into crisis on infinite Earth's
event in 2020. for a Flashpoint movie
that opens the doors to the Multiverse
to seemingly infinite DC cameos even
Nicholas Cage Superman and not include
Grant Gustin on that call sheet and then
only show a version of Teddy Sears face
that he claims he didn't even shoot just
shows that the producers might not have
had the core fan base in mind with these
cameos now when it comes to franchise
movies you have to play to your audience
like if you're gonna do a spider verse
movie You Gotta Give Them Toby Maguire
and age Garfield in the 2023 Flash Film
despite its many good qualities just
failed to deliver the flashpoint event
that was in many fans heads like Michael
Keaton Chris Christopher Reed even
George Clooney they're all beloved but
the age range of people seeing this
movie on opening weekend might consider
Christian Bale to be the older era
Batman of their generation and they're
more likely to see a CGI reanimation of
Christopher Reeve as a bit of an insult
to his memory but again all this only
really affects the highly engaged
viewers who are really plugged into
movie news and the drama who either see
a movie or don't in the opening weekend
it doesn't as much affect the Lesser
engaged viewers who just decide on a
whim to go see a movie a few weeks later
and the Flash just looks like an option
to take the kids to like look at that
chart again those later weeks are still
a big part of the pie and the story on
the flash is not yet fully written but
for the opening weekend which Studios
count on to recoup big portions of their
budgets you gotta win over the Nerds and
by making a Flash movie with the lead
who cannot sell it with an audience who
doesn't recognize it as legitimate
that's how you get an opening weekend
box office disappointment despite what I
still believe to be a good director in a
good script but let me know your
thoughts on this and you can support us
by grabbing some merch at nerd riot.shop
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at EA
boss following rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]